en el vídeo acerca de la autorización
del agua
vimos que si teníamos dos moléculas de
agua neutras una de ellas podría
llevarse unión de hidrógeno que unión de
hidrógeno es simplemente un protón pero
una de estas moléculas podría llevarse
nada más el protón del hidrógeno y nos
quedarían estos iones de aquí ok
unión y drone ya que tiene un protón de
más este hidrógeno de más y un millón
hidróxido acá y la molécula a la que le
quitan el guión de hidrógeno o sea la
molécula la que le quitan sólo este
protón se convierte en el yang hidróxido
estos son los electrones que estaban
formando el enlace entre el oxígeno y el
hidrógeno se quedan en el oxígeno
formando un nuevo par de electrones
libres y dándole una carga negativa a
este ión hidróxido ok también podemos
expresar la autorganización del agua de
esta forma lo que hay tenemos una
molécula de agua neutra y este oxígeno
puede ser que se quede con los dos
electrones de este enlace llevándose el
electrón de este hidrógeno formando un
millón de hidrógeno pero pues unión de
hidrógeno es simplemente un protón
cierto porque el isótopo más común del
hidrógeno únicamente tiene un protón en
el núcleo y el electrón que está dando
vueltas alrededor de ese protón así es
que si le quitamos ese electrón nos
quedamos simplemente con un protón y por
aquí nos queda el ión hidróxido que es
el oxígeno con su hidrógeno que se quedó
con este par de electrones libres
es uno de esos electrones originalmente
era del hidrógeno ahora la razón por la
que estamos haciendo esto es para ver
que aunque tenemos una molécula de agua
neutra y puede ser que suceda esto no es
como que todas las moléculas de agua
estén haciendo esto todo el tiempo pero
esto definitivamente sucede si tienes
una cantidad suficientemente grande de
moléculas de agua y de hecho ya
estuvimos viendo que tanto sucede esto
observando las concentraciones de idron
ya que si estamos hablando de agua pura
a agua pura y aquí lo podemos ver de dos
formas podemos utilizar esta expresión
de la reacción de arriba o la de abajo
ok entonces podemos hablar de la
concentración de hidrógeno h 3 o más si
estamos pensando en esto de aquí arriba
o podemos pensar en la concentración de
iones de hidrógeno si estamos pensando
en esto de aquí abajo y la razón por la
que podemos usar cualquiera de las dos
concentraciones es porque estos iones de
hidrógeno se van a encontrar con una
molécula de agua y van a formar
hidrógeno pero el punto es que en agua
pura a 25 grados centígrados la
concentración del libro neo o lo que es
lo mismo la concentración de lyon de
hidrógeno es 1 por 10 al menos 7 molar y
qué es lo que esto significa pues esto
es simplemente la unidad de la polaridad
así es que tenemos 1
por 10 a lo menos siete moles
litro y si en estos momentos está
costando un poquito de trabajo recordar
qué es lo que son los moles te
recomiendo que veas el vídeo de khan
academy acerca de los moles pero pues
también recordemos lo rápidamente ok
un mol es una cantidad ok así como
podemos tener una docena de algo también
podemos tener un mol de alguna otra cosa
una docena son 12 de cierta cosa y un
mole es 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23 de otra
cosa porque hoy es 60 22 y muchísimos
otros números a la derecha es un numero
supergrande así es que un mol es
simplemente una cantidad muy grande
esta es la concentración de los iones de
hidrógeno en agua pura a 25 grados
centígrados pero pues también nos
podemos preguntar cuál es la
concentración de los iones de hidrógeno
en muchísimas otras sustancias cierto
por ejemplo podemos preguntarnos acerca
del jugo de naranja
jugo de naranja
ok ahora queremos saber cuál es la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno en
el jugo de naranja pero por supuesto
también nos podemos preguntar por cuál
es la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno en el jugo de naranja ahora la
concentración de estos iones varía de
jugo de naranja a jugo de naranja pero
sería bastante normal encontrar un vaso
de jugo de naranja con una concentración
de iones de hidrógeno de 1 por 10 a la
menos 3.5 molar y este número es un
número bastante más grande que este de
aquí aunque bueno mejor vamos a cambiar
un poquito esto para tener un número
cerrado porque ahí vamos a ponerle menos
4 molar definitivamente podemos
encontrar algún jugo de naranja que
tenga esta concentración de iones de
hidrógeno de hecho lo busqué en internet
y hay todo un rango de concentraciones
de iones de hidrógeno que pueden tener
los jugos de naranja
más o menos de 3.3 a 4.2 así es que
seguro podemos encontrar un jugo de
naranja con esta concentración ahora si
nos ponemos a comparar estas dos
concentraciones podemos ver que este
número es bastante más grande que este
otro número este exponente de aquí es
menos negativo por lo cual este es un
número más grande así es que aquí
tenemos una mayor concentración ok
mayor ahora también me puse a buscar
alguna sustancia que tuviera una menor
concentración lo que yo encontré los
blanqueadores y también me metí a
internet me metí a la página de clorox a
buscar cuál es la concentración de los
guiones de hidrógeno del blanqueador
clorox
es 1 por 10 al menos 12 molar y esta
concentración de aquí es una
concentración mucho más baja es una
concentración más chica que la
concentración en el agua pura a 25
grados centígrados que esta es una
concentración menor porque tiene un
exponente más negativo y bueno todo esto
está muy bien está muy padre pero puede
llegar a ser un poco complicado estar
hablando todo el tiempo en notación
científica aunque yo estaba hablando en
un número por 10 a la alguna potencia
entonces para hacer esto más sencillo
las personas inventaron esta idea del ph
h y me puse a buscar por todos lados de
donde salió esta anotación casi todos
están de acuerdo con que esta h se
refiere a la h del hidrógeno mientras
que esta p algunos creen que se refiere
al potencial y otros dicen que es
simplemente una cosa que se quedó
históricamente así nada más pero el ph
es igual a menos el logaritmo y si no
ponemos ninguna base siempre es base 10
así es que podemos poner por aquí el 10
o no ponerlo el ph es igual a menos el
logaritmo base de 10 de la concentración
de los iones de hidrógeno o lo que es lo
mismo es igual a menos el logaritmo base
de 10
y la concentración de los iones de
hidrógeno porque los iones de hidrógeno
siempre se convierten en iones de
hidrógeno así es que estas dos cosas
siempre son lo mismo pero bueno ya que
tenemos aquí una definición del p h
vamos a sacar el ph del agua pura a 25
grados centígrados de este jugo de
naranja y del blanqueador y bueno vamos
a empezar por sacar el ph del agua vamos
a ponerlo por aquí el ph del agua pura
es igual a menos el logaritmo y ahora sí
voy a escribir la base de 10 aunque
podría no escribirla menos el logaritmo
base de 10 de la concentración de iones
de hidrógeno del agua pura lo que hay
que es 1 por 10 a lo menos 7 molar
aunque ya estamos sacando un menos el
logaritmo de la concentración así es que
aquí queremos molar pero bueno 1 por 10
a la menos 7 es simplemente
es al menos 7 cierto y ahora esta parte
de aquí la parte del logaritmo antes de
tomar en cuenta este menos esta parte de
aquí que es lo que nos está diciendo el
logaritmo base 10 nos está preguntando a
qué número tengo que elevar 10 para que
nos quede 10 a la menos 7 y bueno pues
la respuesta a ésta es claramente menos
7 cierto si te parece un poco confuso
esto te recomiendo que repases los
vídeos de logaritmo ok entonces ya que
sacamos el logaritmo tenemos menos menos
siete o sea que tenemos simplemente 7
así es que el ph de agua pura a 25
grados celsius y eso de la temperatura
del agua es súper importante porque
puede afectar la autorización del agua
pero el ph del agua pura a 25 grados
celsius es 7 entonces ya que tenemos el
ph del agua pura
vamos a sacar el ph del jugo de naranja
queremos sacar el p h del jugo de
naranja y ese es igual a menos menos el
logaritmo base de 10 de la concentración
de lyon hidrógeno en el jugo de naranja
y esa concentración es 1 por 10 a la
menos 4 el 1 no nos hace nada entonces
nos queda 10 al menos 4 así es que vamos
a considerar esta parte del logaritmo
aquí lo que tenemos es a qué potencia
tengo que elevar el 10 para que me quede
10 a la menos 4 y bueno pues la
respuesta es menos 4 y entonces nos
queda menos -4 que es 4 de la misma
forma para sacar el p h del blanqueador
tenemos menos el logaritmo de y aquí voy
a simplemente ignorar este 1 por tenemos
10 a la menos 12
el logaritmo base de 10 de 10 a la menos
12 es menos 12 y aquí tenemos este menos
así es que esto es igual a 12 y ahora ya
que tenemos aquí los 3 ph del agua el
jugo y el blanqueador podríamos hacer
una gráfica que podemos poner por aquí
una recta
y ponemos aquí 0 1 2
esta es la gráfica del p h y vamos a
graficar aquí el ph de estas sustancias
ok el agua pura a 25 grados centígrados
va a estar por aquí
agua y algunas veces se refieren a esto
como un ph neutro por otro lado este
jugo de naranja tiene un ph 4 que está
por aquí ok aunque el ph del jugo de
naranja puede variar bastante
dependiendo de si ya se está echando a
perder o no y puede estar más o menos en
este rango ok el jugo de naranja se
encuentra en este rango y después damos
con el blanqueador tiene un ph de 12
osea por aquí el ph del blanqueador
depende de la concentración pero este
blanqueador en particular tiene un ph de
12 que hay tenemos aquí el blanqueador y
bueno también podemos graficar aquí
otras cosas por ejemplo podemos graficar
los jugos gástricos de tu estómago y los
jugos gástricos son bastante ácidos
aunque bueno ahorita todavía no he dicho
nada de la acidez pero vamos a eso en
unos cuantos segundos
que los jugos gástricos están más o
menos en este rango y este rango es el
de los jugos gástricos pero luego
también podemos graficar el nivel de ph
del agua de mar que se encuentra más o
menos en este rango ok
agua de mar ahora también tenemos que
ponernos a pensar en qué es lo que nos
está diciendo esto porque hoy porque hay
que recordar que aquí el ph es una
escala logarítmica y además conforme nos
vamos hacia la derecha va disminuyendo
la concentración ok y eso se debe a este
signo de menos por aquí
ok el blanqueador que tiene un ph de 12
tiene una menor concentración que el
agua ok conforme nos movemos hacia la
derecha hay una menor menor
concentración de iones de hidrógeno y
conforme nos movemos hacia la izquierda
tenemos una mayor concentración de iones
de hidrógeno y en general cuando tenemos
un ph más chico que 7 tendemos a decir
que es ácido
ha sido
tendemos a decir que es ácido y cuando
le agregamos ácidos al agua el ph baja y
se vuelve más ácido por otro lado cuando
tenemos un ph mayor a 7 la mayoría de
las veces vas a escuchar que dicen que
tenemos algo básico aunque seguro te vas
a encontrar a alguien que diría que es
alcalino ok entre más sube el ph más
alcalino se vuelve y la concentración de
los iones de hidrógeno se vuelve cada
vez más chica conforme nos vamos
moviendo a la derecha ok conforme va
subiendo el ph ahora aquí realmente
tenemos que apreciar la naturaleza del
logaritmo porque por ejemplo si te doy
agua de mar que tiene un ph 8 tu puedes
llegar a decir ok esa no es una gran
diferencia con el ph del agua normal que
tiene un ph de 7 pero en realidad esta
diferencia si es considerable
ok porque estamos en una escala
logarítmica
entonces para movernos un lugar hacia la
derecha tenemos una concentración de
iones de hidrógeno 10 veces más pequeña
si por ejemplo nos quisiéramos mover 3
lugares hacia la derecha entonces
tendríamos 10 veces menos 10 veces menos
y 10 veces menos osea tendríamos mil
veces menos concentración de iones de
hidrógeno porque tenemos una milésima
parte de la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno que teníamos por aquí así es
que la verdad está bastante interesante
pensar en la poca concentración de iones
de hidrógeno que hay en un blanqueador
con respecto a la cantidad de iones de
hidrógeno que hay en el agua y también
lo pequeña que es la concentración de
iones de hidrógeno en el agua en
comparación con la concentración de
iones de hidrógeno que hay en el jugo de
naranja